nouvelle édition du journal de la
rédaction ce vendredi 16 janvier bonjour
et bienvenue voici les titres baptiste
vial va défendre les couleurs du lycée
hôtelier de guyancourt lors de la finale
régionale du championnat de france du
dessert il est à l'invité du journal
fermé en cette période hivernale le parc
zoologique de thoiry en profite pour
réaliser des travaux d'envergure le
vivarium à être profondément rénovée et
nous reviendrons en seconde partie du
journal sur l'essentiel de la semaine
des commémorations aux victimes des
attentats au renforcement du plan
vigipirate en passant par les projets de
l'université de versailles saint quentin
et de l'agglomération de saint quentin
en yvelines
je reçois donc pour débuter cette
édition baptiste via le bon jour mais
les veaux au lycée hôtelier de
guyancourt vous venez de remporter la
finale régionale ile de france catégorie
junior du championnat de france du
dessert vous avez 19 ans comment vous
avez réussi à emporter cette finale
régionale qu'elle dessert avez vous
présenté au jury alors j'ai présenté le
dessert qui s'appelle fraîcheur de
pondichéry un dessert qui meurent
sentent tout simplement parce que j'ai
voyagé un an à pondichéry j'ai voulu
transmettre les goûts indien dans cette
assiette en revisitant avec un nouveau
dressage sas est importante pour un
cuisinier et pâtissier de s'enrichir de
son expérience personnelle de ses
voyages de ses dégoûts
oui carrément et qu'a fait la différence
je pense mais je pense que le dessert
avait vraiment une histoire et c'est ça
qui qui a donné envie aux clients au
jury ce qu'il faut savoir vendre le
dessert au moment de présenter je pense
que oui ça sert et comment ça se passe
justement une finale sur un tel une un
tel championnat vous vous préparez tout
seul vous êtes aidez ensuite il faut le
défendre justement faut expliquer ce que
vous avez voulu faire oui alors c'est ça
en fait je me suis inscrit avec mon chef
qui m'a complètement soutenu c'est lui
qui m'a appris toutes les techniques
on a beaucoup travaillé notamment sur
l'hygiène qui est très très importante
lors d'un championnat
l'organisation mais je pense que pour
le joueur du championnat il faut être
surtout fort niveau mental parce que la
recette on la connaît avant mais il faut
être fort ce jour mentalement vous venez
avec votre recette on vous impose pas
quelque chose sur ce non non non c'est
vraiment libre on doit présenter une
recette de notre choix et on doit la
défendre vous avez toujours eu cette
passion pour le dessert comment c'est
venu vous étiez plutôt parti vert vers
la question d'âme ou plus classique
alors j'étais parti sur ce que j'ai fait
un bac pro cuisine donc trois ans
j'étais parti sur le côté salé et donc
lors de mon voyage en vain que j'ai pu
faire un stage dans des palaces que en
pâtisserie et c'est là que j'ai
découvert ma passion pour la pâtisserie
pour moi il ya plus de liberté de
dressage de
l'esthétisme tous à la barre comment ça
se passe aujourd'hui concrètement la
formation pour vous au lycée hôtelier
c'est uniquement dédié au sucre est
justement maintenant oui voila je suis
en mention complémentaire
dessert à l'assiette et je pense
continuer sur cette voie voir travailler
le chocolat les glaces voilà différents
sujets mais toujours en rapport avec la
pâtisserie parce que là vous préparé ce
championnat à la finale nationale pour
autant les études ce n'est pas terminée
vous en étau dans votre formation alors
j'ai passé mon premier examen donc cela
les seins il ya une deuxième ace c'est
un deuxième examen et l'examen final qui
se passera en juin avec l'école et voilà
je le dois le passé pour avoir
l'intention donc il faut passer cet
examen et en plus il faut préparer la
finale puisque ce sera en mars juste par
rapport à la préparation des desserts
vous parliez de ce que vous avez
découvert et appris lors de vos stages
aide lors de votre découverte à travers
le monde en quelque sorte pour autant il
faut faire apprécier le dessert aux
autres lorsqu'on prépare un dessert
c'est les autres qui doivent apprécier
avant soi même ça aussi c'est une
difficulté supplémentaire s'est trouvé
des textures des mélanges qui pourront
un maquis pourront séduire un jury un
client oui mais voilà c'est ça j'ai
vraiment voulu jouer sur les textures
différentes les goûts différents avoir
un dessert léger fruité qui qui se mange
facilement après un repas pour digérer
par exemple mais si on est obligé soi
même des mails dessert qu'on prépare ah
oui forcément mais moi personnellement
je la or et c'est pour ça que j'ai voulu
le défendre et j'ai encore le défendre
pour la pour la finale en mars
hilale en mars effectivement à l'école
hôtelière savoie léman à thonon les
bains vous allez présenter le même
dessert le me dessert et en plus de ça
il y a donc une heure en plus pour un
panier qu'on ne connaît pas donc 10 des
cires l'idée serre supplémentaires ont
ça fait vingt dessert en quatre heures
alors le fait de représenter le même
dessert on n'avait pas peur d'être sûr
sur un acquis non il faut vouloir
travailler en permanence vous leurrez
essayé en permanence je l'aide est gelée
déjà retravaillé donc cette semaine
notamment l'acidité du sorbet dans la
recette qui pour les jurys étaient un
petit peu trop fort tu sais ces petits
détails qui font la différence je pense
le jour de la finale et c'est ça que
vous travaillez aujourd'hui vous a été
aidé épaulé par le lycée hôtelier
justement oui par les chefs du lycée
hôtelier et notamment à partir de lundi
par monsieur benghanem trianon palace
qui m'aidera pour la finale comment vous
y passez combien de temps combien
commence à s'organiser dans le planning
alors cette préparation c'est très
simple quand je suis au lycée c'est
toute la journée jusqu'à ce que le chef
me disent que ça soit bon et à partir de
lundi donc je serai un stage jusqu'à 17
heures et après 17 heures c'est le chef
qui me diras tu peux te lancer sûreté
préparation jusqu'à je ne sais pas à
quelle heure mais ça généralement ça se
finit tard donc vous aurez un bon
planning sur les neuf prochains mois
pour préparer cette cette finale et le
lycée hôtelier qui mise beaucoup sur
vous j'imagine mais forcément vous qui
vous soutiennent le président du
concours du dessert le championnat de
france du dessert c'est thierry marx ça
vous impressionne d'être de côtoyer des
gens comme ça c'est un enrichissement
aussi complémentaires c'est oui c'est un
enrichissement ça c'est sûr ça me ferait
plaisir de le rencontrer pour la
première fois c'est vrai que ça me fait
un petit peu peur mais bon je suis là
pour gagner donc j'ai tout faire pour
cette là pour gagner on l'a bien compris
que vous remportiez au final ce concours
ou pas qu'est ce que ça vous aura
apporté est ce que ce sera un plus pour
la suite professionnelle pour votre
carrière aussi à lui complètement je
pense que l'univers des concours n'a
rien à voir avec l'entreprise c'est
vraiment de l'organisation
beaucoup de travail donc oui c'est sûr
sa portée pour plus tard et ce
championnat vous vouliez vous y inscrire
dès le début c'est vous qui avez fait la
démarche et même avant d'être dans cette
dans cette année de préparer vous
l'aviez déjà évoqué avec vous oui voilà
c'est ça l'année dernière j'étais avec
mon chef donc en terminale bac pro et
c'est lui qui m'avait repéré qui en
avait parlé à mon chef pâtissier de
cette année c'est comme ça que j'ai pu
prendre connaissance du championnat et
m'inscrire directement la mention pour
pouvoir le passer d'accord une dernière
question est ce que vous savez s'il ya
déjà des élèves du lycée hôtelier qui
l'ont remporté de lui en cours n'ont
jamais mais il ya déjà eu un finaliste
qui a passé les régionales c'était en
1995 guillaume salle si je me suis même
bien oui aujourd'hui à 2000 à 2015 qui
débute et vous êtes finalistes et on
vous souhaite bonne chance pour ce
concours national du dessert finale en
mars et vous reviendrez son plateau pour
nous présenter ce dessert déjà qu'on
aura hâte de goûter et puis bien
évidemment pour fêter votre victoire
merci à vous merci direction et touahri
à présent pour ce journal le parc
animalier fermé pour l'hiver une période
qui permet de réaliser quelques travaux
le vivarium va être rénovée anthony rech
le vivarium est en train de changer de
peau les employés du zoo de thoiry ont
dû abattre un arbre de 160 ans et
réutilise aujourd'hui le bois pour le
mettre en scène dans l'antre des
reptiles en fait tout sur site en fait
on est en cycle court c'est là qu'en
fait auto de bardage bois a été fait en
châtaignier donc on a coupé en fête du
bois en forêt on la fondue et on en fait
du bardage donc c'est ça complète notre
démarche environnementale
ouvert en 97 le vivarium n'a jamais
connu de rénovation grâce au morceau de
bois récupéré des gradins vont être
installés en face des animaux pendant
cette période de chantier les soigneurs
doivent s'assurer que les pensionnaires
passent l'hiver sans encombre les
warrants de toute façon sont maintenues
dans leur terrarium à température
constante
élevé que ce soit hiver ou été la
différence pour univers c'est que du
coup ils peuvent pas profiter de leurs
espaces extérieurs leur enclos extérieur
si les aménagements doivent être visuel
et agréable pour les visiteurs il
améliore également le bien être de
l'animal certains travaux sont en cours
comme cette pirogue dans l'espace des
tortues et le bruit des tronçonneuses ne
semble pas du tout les déranger là c'est
au contraire la curiosité qui
l'emportent et on a la femelle var en
peau de veau rats qui venait dans nos
pieds
regardez les outils aux vernets et donc
au contraire c'est une distraction
salle et divertit de leur quotidien et
puis à priori apprécie plutôt quoi une
fois les travaux terminés cette anna
combat vers long de 4 mètres 50 sera
transféré dans le vivarium à côté de ses
cousins python autre nouveauté 2015 un
couple dit guad venue des fidji
débarquera touahri que vous pourrez
découvrir à partir du 14 février
voilà nous allons présent revenir sur
l'essentiel de la semaine est tout
d'abord et cette mobilisation après les
attentats qui ont touché la france à
montigny le bretonneux notamment les
habitants se sont retrouvés à l'appel de
la municipalité une marche samedi
dernier qui s'est étiré de l'avenue
nicolas avoue jusqu'à l'hôtel de ville à
laquelle ont participé à des citoyens
mais aussi des élus un cortège mené par
le maire de la commune président de
l'agglomération michel laugier entouré
d'autres élus de la ville dans le
cortège des représentants des différents
cultes de nombreux enfants également une
délégation d'élus unis montrent un s'est
rendu dimanche au défilé parisien et
dimanche dernier à la même heure 15
heures un défilé était aussi organisée
sur le parvis de la gare à la mairie
c'est à rambouillet environ dix mille
personnes ya participé et ont participé
c'était le plus hors grands ont défilé
dans le département
une fois de plus tous unis derrière une
seule volonté rendre hommage aux
victimes et dire non à la barbarie avec
pour unité le drapeau bleu blanc rouge
et je suis charlie un rassemblement
d'élus et de citoyens je pense que le
message est bien sûr et très très très
important c'est l'avenir de notre pays
quelque part qui se joue depuis quelques
heures et dire écoutez c'est aussi aux
représentants de la république
de porter ces messages ce que nous avons
fait d'une façon très très humble
aujourd'hui à rambouillet mais avec
aussi beaucoup de force oui c'est de
l'émotion mais de l'eau mais l'émotion
compétentes et avec toute la force qui
nous unis ont lavé aujourd'hui haranguer
nous entre en résistance pour que nos
libertés soient sauvés je suis
abdelkader j'en suis fier mais ma
république est fière aussi d'avoir
abdelkader à la tête d'une
circonscription telle que celle de
rambouillet chargé d'histoire changer de
toute l'histoire de la france c'est pas
une réaction en particulier à charlie
hebdo ça aurait pu être le canard ça
aurait pu être n'importe quel autre
journal c'est c'est la même chose on tue
la liberté d'expression charlie hebdo
était bien sûr réputé pour ses
caricatures les traits de crayon célèbre
de cabu charb et tant d'autres
leur mort a éveillé chez certains roboly
temps d envie de prendre le crayon j'ai
eu envie de sheba javier jacquot pas
dans le photo club où je suis qui avait
fait 1 avait fait un croquis puis j'ai
eu les yeux des cages je subis une bonne
feuille de papier que j'ai j'ai laissé
faire le crayon c'est comme ça c'était
un moyen de rendre hommage c'est un bien
grand mot mais j'ai eu envie de faire je
les fais dans cette marche républicaine
se côtoyaient toutes les générations et
même les citoyens de demain une occasion
pour certains parents de partager leurs
valeurs
la semaine a été très difficile avant
tout pour nous et aussi pour eux c'était
un choc
pour toute la famille on leur a transmis
voilà qu'est ce qu'on a ressenti nous et
et on a été touchés droite au coeur
voilà on a pu leur transmettre ce que ce
en quoi on croit et ce en quoi on pense
dix mille personnes ont défilé à
rambouillet s'ajoutant ainsi aux près de
4 millions de français qui se sont
rassemblés un peu partout dans le pays
faisant de cette journée un événement
historique
et mercredi matin il fallait se lever
tôt si vous souhaitiez acquérir le
nouveau numéro de charlie hebdo
l'hebdomadaire initialement attiré à 3
millions d'exemplaires pour l'occasion
étaient en rupture de stock rapidement
après sa mise en vente au vu de
l'engouement du public la décision
d'augmenter le tirage à 5 millions a été
prise écoutez le témoignage de ce
libraire
voilà le témoignage du libraire on va
pour l'instant voilà on écoute le
témoignage donc du libraire à présent ce
matin c'était exceptionnel il y avait
une queue je crois qu'il y avait une
cinquantaine de personnes qui
attendaient malheureusement on n'en a
pas eu assé on en a eu que 80 on en
avait commandé 200 mais je pense que
demain il y aura un réapprovisionnement
assez massif du sancy ça fait 13 ans que
je fais ce métier c'est la première fois
que je vois ça un engouement comme ça
pour un journal dont on toujours qu'une
commission sur la vente du journal donc
il est avant de 3 euros nous récupère
les sauts et tous nous sera prélevé pour
aller
au journal charlie hebdo rue et que
pensez vous de cet engouement autour de
la mise en vente de ce numéro de charlie
hebdo quelques réponses avec ce micro
trottoir
j'espère qu'elle sera pas uniquement sur
castrés surplus sur le long terme voilà
mais je pense que réaction salutaire il
faut que charlie hebdo coop qui continue
pour moi il y a beaucoup de gens qui se
disaient tu leurs amis alors qu'ils
l'étaient pas avant après c'est terrible
ce qui s'est passé il faut rester unis
pour pour que ça n'arrive pas mais dire
qu'on et leurs amis alors qu'on les
pages s'émeut
enlève un peu là
c'est une belle journée voilà que tous
ces défis les cons on espère que ça dure
voilà mais bon
c'est triste pour les familles je pense
que c'est une très bonne chose d'une
part parce que c'est terrible ce qui
s'est passé chez eux et puis que c'est
important de leur montrer notre soutien
par rapport à ça et aussi pour défendre
les valeurs de la république est ce que
vous comptez acheter le nouveau numéro
j'essaye mais je ne trouve pas
les anonymes comme les personnalités qui
se sont mobilisés du côté des politiques
je vous propose d'écouter est la
réaction de pierre bédier le président
ump du conseil général des yvelines et
sept au micro de nicolas kirillovitch
pour radio sensations intégralité de cet
entretien à retrouver sur l'antenne de
nos confrères ce dimanche dans le raid
aux politiques
car bédié bonsoir bonsoir évidemment
avant de débuter cette émission toutes
nos pensées se tournent vers les
victimes des événements tragiques ont
lieu la semaine passée en france
policiers civils journalistes agents
d'entretien toute la rédaction de radio
sensations se joint à moi pour
manifester son soutien aux proches des
victimes et un conseil général dédié
tout le conseil général des yvelines
également à ce propos pierre bédier vous
avez été actif depuis les attentats qui
ont touché le pays vous avez notamment
demandé la gratuité des transports pour
se rendre à la marche républicaine de
dimanche dernier une gratuité que vous
avez obtenus en tant qu'homme politique
vous devez montrer l'exemple c'est
important oui bien sûr que c'est
important mais c'est pas tant
en tant qu'homme politique qu'on
s'exprime dans ces moments là c'est en
tant que citoyen engagé
ayant plus de responsabilités que les
autres à titre personnel par exemple je
convaincu qu'il fallait que tous les
élus défilent ensemble moi j'ai défilé
en famille
est ce que c'est c'était des moments je
crois de deux justement de deux fois
individuelle or la république qu'il
fallait exprimer
encore de satory à présent c'est à
versailles jean yves le drian le
ministre de la défense s'est rendu cette
semaine c'était jeudi matin auprès des
militaires déployés dans le cadre du
plan vigipirate depuis l attaque
meurtrière contre charlie hebdo le 7
janvier le plan vous le savez a été
relevé au niveau alerte attentes à 6
mille militaires sont maintenant être
dispersées en ile de france pour une
durée de trois semaines environ 90 13
elodie moines
11h30 ce matin le ministre de la défense
arrive sur le camp de satory à
versailles jean yves le drian est venu
accueillir les militaires envoyés en ile
de france pour participer au plan
vigipirate alerte attentats habitués a
activé la cellule 14 juillet pour
accueillir chaque année les centaines de
soldats pour le défilé c'est aussi ici à
satory quête assurer la grande partie de
l'hébergement de l'alimentation de
l'équipement et du transport des 6000
militaires déployés pour l'occasion en
ile-de-france un déploiement jugé très
rapide par le ministre le contrat
opérationnel de protection est inscrit
dans la loi de programmation prévoyait
d'après la décision du président de la
république il ya une semaine de
mobilisation pour atteindre le chiffre
de dix mille hommes on l'a fait en trois
jours vous l'avez fait en trois jours
les militaires l'ont fait entre jour
dont c'est une réactivité tout à fait
remarquable
accompagné de jean pierre raffarin
président de la commission des affaires
étrangères et de la défense du sénat le
ministre salue ces militaires arrivés
quelques heures plus tôt
ce matin dans des salles réquisitionnées
pour la distribution et les militaires
c'est qu'ils paient encore et gilet
pare-balles tenue casque gants livrés au
fur et à mesure ces militaires seront
ensuite dispersées dans toute
l'ile-de-france dès à présent les sites
sensibles sont protégés par les
militaires en bonne articulation avec
les forces de police et les forces de
gendarmerie pour assurer la sécurité
notre pays face aux menaces qui sont
maintenant au total sur l'ensemble du
territoire national dix mille cinq cents
militaires sont déployés la visite aura
duré un peu plus d'une heure elle se
termine par l'hymne national
depuis le 7 janvier les yvelines sont
donc passés en plan vigipirate attend un
résultat la présence massive des forces
de l'ordre dans certains points de grand
rassemblement un dispositif qui a des
conséquences sur notre quotidien
chaque jour ils sont plusieurs centaines
à patrouiller sur le département depuis
le déclenchement du plan vigipirate au
niveau attentats les forces de l'ordre
se sont déployées en masse sur les sites
dits sensibles une présence quotidienne
qui soulage
c'est très rassurant d'avoir les
policiers qui se promènent le long des
quais c'est très rassurant prendre non
les trois patrouilles et ce malade et
sait si on a besoin ils sont à très loin
par sites sensibles il faut entendre les
grands rassemblements de foules comme
les magasins le château de versailles ou
encore les moyens de transport les lieux
de culte et les entreprises de presse
sont également des zones à surveiller
les policiers qui patrouillent sur la
voie publique ou dans les lieux publics
doivent faire tout d'abord attention aux
éventuelles menaces des comportements
atypiques de la part de personnes des
colis piégés par exemple ils doivent
également se rendre disponible auprès de
la population afin de renseigner et de
rassurer l'élément
qui consiste à devoir rassurer la
population est très important il faut
éviter les psychoses ils aient peur
inutile et irraisonné chaque matin
l'ensemble des services de sécurité
publique du département se réunit autour
du préfet pour faire un bilan au jour le
jour des actions en place une situation
exceptionnelle qui a eu des conséquences
sur la vie quotidienne des forces de
l'ordre nous avons par exemple supprimer
un certain nombre de congés nous avons
supprimé les modules de formation et
d'entraînement de même que l'ensemble
des personnels qu'ils pouvaient être
affectés à des tâches de support
technique ont été basculés sur la voie
publique pour
maximiser le potentiel de travail auprès
de nos concitoyens
depuis le déclenchement du niveau
attentats les faits de délinquance sont
en baisse sur les i mua
on en vient l'actualité plus local de
cette semaine écoulée michel laugier le
président de la communauté
d'agglomération de saint quentin a
présenté donc cette semaine ses voeux
pour la première fois depuis son
élection en mars quelles sont les
grandes orientations à retenir réponse
avec ce sujet
j'aurais préféré être président il ya
dix ans une période dorée où tout
pouvait être envisagé une phrase
prononcée par michel logis le président
de la communauté d'agglomération de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines à l'occasion
des voeux car l'heure est aux économies
aujourd'hui par exemple entre l'année
2014 et 2015 tu te trouvais 6 millions
d'économies il bien que les dotations
qui fondent comme neige au soleil pèse
énormément ce notre budget c'est pas que
le cadre que l'état glossy tous ces cas
dans toutes les communes c'est pour ça
que j'ai aussi parlé du pacte financier
qui maintient cabab de certaines
garanties financières entre la
communauté d'agglomération et les
communes mais c'est vrai que le maître
mot aujourd'hui il faut trouver il faut
faire des économies on n'a plus les
moyens que nous avions avant dé
d'agglomération il ya déjà du changement
il ya déjà une autre gestion il ya déjà
notre organisation de strativa aussi et
il ya déjà des directives très précises
qui sont donnés trois audits sont en
cours les résultats seront connus d'ici
la fin avril il ya des certainement des
dmm mutualisation à faire à certains
endroits il ya certainement des
améliorations dans la période où de
toute façon ça a été dit c'est dit par
tout le monde les ressources sont pour
les collectivités territoriales en
baisse mais en même temps pour nous il y
avait aussi des secteurs qui sont
extrêmement important essentiel ce
serait une erreur par exemple de toucher
sur le secteur culturel sur le secteur
associatif qui est aujourd'hui crée du
lien social créé du vivre ensemble et
qui créent de l'emploi outre ces
économies à réaliser des rendez vous
d'envergure attendre l'agglomération des
rendez vous sportifs comme les
championnats du monde de cyclisme en
février prochain et d'autres plus
politiques comme la refonte du périmètre
de l'agglomération qui évoluera au 1er
janvier 2016 michel laugier de rappeler
sa vision du grand saint quentin
accueillant demain les communes de
plaisir les clés villepreux maurepas et
coignières tout en renforçant ses liens
avec le plateau de saclay
je n'ai qu'une seule ambition qu'un seul
objectif faire de saint quentin en
yvelines un des symboles de l'excellence
à la française a conclu le président de
l'agglomération
que réserve à présent en 2015 à
l'université de versailles
saint-quentin-en-yvelines son président
a livré quelques indices jeudi lors de
sa cérémonie de voeux quatre régulateurs
des grilles fermées une chaîne et un
filtrage à l'entrée seuls les membres du
conseil d'administration sont autorisés
à entrer au siège de l'université de
versailles-saint-quentin des mesures
prises pour éviter les débordements du
mois de descendre ou des étudiants
s'étaient invités au conseil
d'administration pour témoigner de leur
crainte des craintes à propos du budget
2015 toujours d'actualité au
gouvernement a mis la priorité jeunesse
complètement de côté du coup il fallait
taper du poing sur la table cette fois
c'est ce que je leur dire c'est en gros
soyez avec nous n'acceptez pas
l'austérité dans les budgets nous soyez
avec nous revendiquer vous aussi le fait
que l'état redonne de l'argent plus
d'argent chaque année comporte pas lieu
d'être aux dépenses obligatoires et
qu'on arrête de couper dans les
formations que les étudiants arrête de
payer les pots cassés
l'unef n'a pas prévu aujourd'hui
d'envahir la réunion le vote est
symbolique le budget de l'université est
sous tutelle du rectorat un plan
d'économies a été mis en place des
filières ont été fermés comme la licence
staps à versailles des économies lourde
de conséquences selon le syndicat cgt
nous avons des personnels qui sont
partis de leur plein gré vu l'état de
l'université et le budget qui est
effectivement
insuffisant nous ne revendications sont
de bien sûr demandé aux ministères plus
d'argent pour que nous puissions
fonctionner simplement correctement le
sarc actuellement les dernières nous
avons fonctionné avec 25% de budget pour
les labos et actuellement nous avons il
a été voté et décidée par la direction
un budget à 50% pour les labos du côté
des enseignants ne comprends pas bien
ces réductions juge est facultative avec
ses budgets ils s'attendent à une
situation légèrement meilleur qu'en 2014
mais sans grande satisfaction ni 15 va
être une année difficile a encore pour
les personnels et pour faire fonctionner
et tourner nos informations c'est
incontestable tout ce qu'on peut espérer
c'est que le ministère en traits d'un
moment un autre vraiment conscience
qu'un du véhicule comme ailleurs nous
sommes dans une sous location qui est
tronic maintenant et qu'il n'est plus
qui n'est pas tenable sur le long terme
si nous avons des budgets à compresser
des budgets réduits ce n'est pas parce
qu'il faut faire plus d'économies dans
l'absolu c'est parce que le gouvernement
fait le choix de donner six milliards et
demi en crédit impôt recherche sur des
dispositifs dont tout le monde sait en
tout cas beaucoup le disent qu'ils sont
plutôt relativement inefficace on c'est
ça la vraie la vraie clé je dirai après
100 live rien en fait que dans chaque
établissement il ya des choix à faire
les choix politiques de gestion il n'y a
aucun problème avec ça le conseil
d'administration a duré plusieurs heures
dans l'après midi le budget a été voté
résultat 17 pour 8 contre et une
abstention
c'est la fin de ce journal a rendez vous
dès lundi aux mêmes horaires pour un
nouveau point complet sur l'actualité
locale d'ici là très bon week-end